A little while back, I was having a conversation
with another creator about combo decks,
and that conversation went something like this:
“I don’t know that I’d
consider combo an archetype.”
“What would you consider it, then? What
broader category does it belong to?”
“I don’t know, a finisher? A thing a deck can do?”
Hmmm.
On a somewhat related note, last year on a
podcast I was ranking archetypes in commander,
and I said that I don’t think the reanimator
archetype is one that’s likely to feel good
in commander. Down in the comments, there was a
chorus of people pushing back, saying something
to the effect of “but Snail, graveyard decks
are fun! I love my Sevinne’s Reclamation.” This
is interesting to me because I don’t consider
Sevinne’s Rec a reanimator card. A nice little
utility spell for graveyard decks? Yes. A
card played in proper reanimator decks? No.
That phrase “proper” might begin to elucidate the
issue, though. I’m saying a phrase, and it turns
out that my definition of that phrase differs from
a lot of other people’s definition. Let’s go back
to the combo example. What do I think about the
statement that combo isn’t an archetype, it’s
just a thing some decks do? Well, in the context
of Commander, it’s a pretty reasonable assertion.
Combos are a pretty common way of finishing
off opponents in mid to high power EDH games,
so trying to categorize them as an archetype feels
a little tricky. Is every deck that wins with a
combo sometimes a “combo deck”? If not, where
is the line on what constitutes a combo deck?
What percentage of games need to be won using
a combo, what amount of deck space dedicated
to pulling off the combo? It’s a messy thing
to try and properly quantify. So, why do I and
many other players think of combo as an archetype?
Put simply, it’s because commander inherits a lot
of cultural signifiers from 60 card formats, and
combo is more of a well-defined archetype there.
In most 20-life 1v1 formats, combos aren’t
actually the best way to close out a game most
of the time. This is particularly true for ones
that feature higher-powered interaction, and we
can see this in the most popular wincons in Legacy
and Vintage. Vengevine, Glaring Fleshwraker,
Psychic Frog, White Plume Adventurer—these are
simply extremely efficient creatures rather than
being part of an A+B infinite combo. The reason
for this is simple—it’s just not necessary to
use an infinite combo to kill a single 20-health
opponent on a normal timeline, you’d be cracking
eggs with a sledgehammer. For this reason, combo
decks are generally a more specific thing, decks
whose gameplan centers around executing a combo
because it offers some advantage in speed, or
strengths in some specific matchups. Not all decks
that win with combos would be widely considered
combo decks—some might be a control deck that uses
a combo as a compact finisher—but the Venn diagram
is close enough to a circle that these things are
often viewed as one and the same. If you win with
a combo, you’re probably playing a combo deck, and
vice versa. This, once again, contrasts with the
commander format, where combos are frequently the
best way to close out games in a wide variety of
different decks. And, the more I thought about it,
the more I found myself agreeing with Commander
Baumi—Combo isn't really an archetype, it's just
a type of finisher, a thing that some decks do.
This is paralleled when we think about reanimator.
The point of confusion between myself and the
YouTube commenters was that when I think of
reanimator, I first and foremost think of the
archetype as seen in modern or legacy. This is
a very specific type of deck where the goal is
to dump a horrifying threat into the graveyard
through an entomb effect or a discard spell, and
then use a reanimation spell to bring it back
out into play as early as turn 2. The threats
used for this are typically either massive value
sources like Griselbrand or oppressive bombs like
Archon of Cruelty, and the goal of the deck is
to capitalize on the massive tempo swing of a big
threat coming down so early in order to snowball
into a win. As I said in the podcast episode,
I don't think this strategy is a very good idea
to replicate in EDH—trying to snowball a turn two
or three threat into a win seems very likely to
result in simply getting pummeled by the table,
unless the threat is something so disgustingly
oppressive that it mostly removes the ability
of opponents to play the game, a la Jin
Gitaxias or Void Winnower. A deck that
has some strong follow-up options might work,
but the purest versions of the play pattern are
likely to either result in pathetic failure or a
generational pubstomp. The vibes are bad. However,
the commenters on that episode weren't thinking
of what I was thinking of about reanimator—they
were thinking about the act of reanimation.
Actual reanimator decks don't really exist
in EDH due to the reasons I just laid out, so
when EDH players hear "the reanimator archetype"
they think about a general graveyard deck that
reanimates things here or there. In other words,
reanimation as a thing that some decks do.
And I can’t even say they’re wrong for that,
because in practice that's basically
all reanimator is within the EDH format.
This pattern continues onto other so-called
archetypes. Take control—I have an idea of
what control means to me, various other people
have an idea of what control means to them,
but when you get into the broader image of it
in the EDH community it mostly comes down to
two things—counterspells and board wipes.
If a deck board wipes every turn or two or
counters multiple spells a turn cycle, that's
a control deck. Think Baral, Child of Alara,
that sort of thing. I also see this whenever I
do deck reviews—I start digging into a deck that
somebody has labeled a control deck, and it's
a massive pile of removal and counterspells.
Now, unlike reanimator or combo, I do think
control decks meaningfully exist in EDH,
and they can actually look relatively healthy
within the broader ecosystem. The most prominent
feature of a control deck, to me, is a multi-card
engine that repeats effects that generate value
or deal with opposing permanents. Flickering
is a common way of facilitating this, as are
graveyard synergies that recycle already-played
cards. This sort of engine then helps a deck
scale into the late game to the point where it's
nigh-unstoppable. In the context of this sort of
deck, removing opposing threats is important,
but so is not removing opposing permanents,
picking out the threats that can be left on board
safely while the control deck spends its resources
building value instead, while still dealing with
the ones that are more immediately problematic.
So, this is my vision of control in EDH,
and I think it's one that has a highly
dynamic play pattern, both to pilot
and to play against. The problem is,
it's about as effective as a massive
pile of board wipes. Wiping the board
in a four player free-for-all format is
just a really, really strong thing to do,
and so a lot of players end up building these
board-wipe-tribal monstrosities that constantly
flush away all creatures or even all nonland
permanents, thereby removing all the thinking
of what permanents can be allowed to stick
around for a bit. Can I honestly say these
aren't control decks? No, I really can't. A
dainty little flicker-archaeomancer pile is
just as valid of a control deck in EDH as a board
wipe pile, that's just how the format works. And,
"board wipe pile" doesn't even really refer
to a specific set of goals or play patterns.
It's just a thing a deck can do—playing
a board wipe—cranked up to its limit,
and paired with whatever else a player might
feel like doing that works in tandem with that.
There are plenty more examples of this to be
found. Whereas 60 card aggro decks have cutthroat
optimized mana curves and very distinct play
patterns, aggro decks in commander are generally
just midrange decks that are stronger earlier in
the game, such is the challenge of playing in a
three opponent, 40 life format. Some aggro decks
can get around the three opponent issue by having
most of their damage be pings, or get around the
40 life issue by using commander damage or infect,
but basically none can dodge both of these
challenges, and as a result all of their speeds
will be mediated by the need to punch harder
and stick around longer. We can also think about
classic archetypes that are borderline disallowed
at most tables—ponza, prison, and discard. In a
cutthroat 1v1 format these are fixtures, but in
the social format of EDH they’re endlessly taboo.
So, this is the general point I’m trying to make
here—the commander format does not have distinct
archetypes in the same way most other formats
do. And actually, the phrase “archetype” has
increasingly been phased out in the commander
player lexicon in favor of a different term:
“theme”. I’ve kind of noticed this in some ways,
but it’s taken a handful of these run-ins with
so-called archetypes to really cement things
in my brain. In the year of our lord 2026,
commander decks don’t fit into dramatically
different playstyles, but rather different
flavors of existence. They have things that
they do rather than things that they are.
However, this observation demands a couple
follow-up questions. For one, did commander ever
feature a lot of distinct archetypes? Was it once
holy and pure, only now marred by a decade and a
half of precon designs pushing decks in a more
generic direction? In my subjective experience
the answer is yes, but that’s only because
most of my pre-2023 commander experience was
playing with a group of ten budget decks that
me and my friends specifically designed to fit
into different archetypes. Even there the aggro,
control, and combo decks felt a little midrangy
compared to their 60-card counterparts, but there
was still a distinctness that doesn’t exist as
much in commander more broadly. Personally I miss
that differentiation a bit, but it’s definitely
a reflection of a cool micro-format me and my
friends built more so than it is a reflection
of how commander used to be. At its inception in
the 90s, commander decks were janky and disjointed
to the max, a collection of all of the interesting
and wacky cards that didn’t quite fit into any of
the 60 card decks of the day. Anybody who’s played
in a chaos draft can tell you, when the cohesion
of a card pool drops, the result is that decks
plans get simpler and more generic. To be clear,
this is a different style of generic than
modern commander decks. These days decks
tend to be stronger overall, featuring both a bit
more cohesion and also a lot more card draw and
other vegetables to hold things together. It’s
still a form of continuity, though—commander
decks have always been a bit more generic and a
bit less cohesive than their 60-card counterparts.
The second question worth asking is, is this fact
good? Is the fact that commander differs from 60
card formats in not having conventional archetypes
a problem? For the most part I would say no, it’s
not a problem. As I said, I enjoy when commander
decks are a bit more distinct from one another,
when they fill different roles and peak
in power at different points in the game,
but commander decks looking a lot like one another
is very much something to be expected. In a 100
card singleton deck, there will be a natural
limit to how specific a deck’s gameplan can be,
and that will result in more shared attributes
between decks. In a 4 player, 40 life format,
everything will be slower, and as a result
decks will be expected to grind at least into
the midgame. This also means that almost all
decks will want card draw, ramp, and removal,
unlike in 60 card formats where some decks are
able to get away with little to none in one or
more of these categories. Precons have certainly
prodded commander in a particular direction,
but I don’t think that direction represents
anything aberrant or unexpected. Maybe if I
grew up playing the super-duper janky version
of commander I’d be resenting the gentle power
creep and gradual streamlining of
precons, but I didn’t so I don’t.
The one part of this that is a little less ideal
is the fact that non-commander formats have become
so secondary within the game. It’s absolutely
not a problem for a more casual format with
less clearly differentiated decks to exist, but
what about when it’s the default? I remember back
in the early to mid 2010s when commander lived
alongside other formats. Somebody who wanted to
play commander with their friends could do so,
since most people had a commander deck or two,
but they also wouldn’t have too hard a
time finding somebody who wanted to play
standard or modern or pauper or even kitchen
table 60 card Magic. Contrast that with now,
where it feels like the average Magic player is
more likely to have a 4th or 5th commander deck
than they are to have a 60 card deck put together
and ready to play with, and they probably aren’t
even interested in playing in a draft. And just
to be clear, there are absolutely reasons that
commander has succeeded to the extent it
has, reasons that go beyond the outsized
level of support it gets by Wizards of the Coast
compared to other formats. It’s great as a casual,
social format. But, it’s worth keeping
in mind what we might be missing out on.
Thanks for watching, and thanks to Archidekt
for supporting the channel. Archidekt actually
has an advanced search feature for the decks
within it, and this includes colors, commander,
inclusion of a specific card, and deck tags like
the themes or archetypes it fits. Want to see what
various people consider to be a reanimator deck,
or dive into the various lists on Archidekt that
feature the card Wild Research? This is your
ticket. I also want to thank Dragonshield for
supporting the channel. If you want to pick up
some of the awesome new guild dual mattes while
also supporting the channel, you can follow the
link in the description and use code “salubrious”
at checkout for 5% off. If you want to support the
channel more directly, consider joining my patreon
or becoming a YouTube member. I’m currently
taking submissions for my next deck review, and
if you want a shot at getting your deck reviewed,
becoming a supporter is your way of doing that.